researchers have come up with a new 3D printing
technology that makes objects appear all at
once, seemingly from nowhere.
The new approach is built on a technology
for pinpoint delivery of radiation in cancer patients.
The researchers use a computer-controlled
digital light projector to cast images through
a rotating clear container holding a photosensitive gel.
The projected images are based on a
scan of a 3d object.
As the container rotates, photons entering
from different angles meet at select spots in the gel.
Where they meet, their combined energy
solidifies the gel.
Where photons don’t combine with enough
energy, they pass on through without altering
the material.
The approach is fast, able to create complex
objects, such as a centimeter-sized copy of
“The Thinker” in just minutes
It can also create 3D plastic parts around
existing objects, such as a plastic handle
around a metal screwdriver shaft.
So while this device may not print
Earl Grey Tea (hot) on demand,
it does induce some of the same sense of wonder.